hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg with me is Al I'm sorry
how y'all doin Tariq Tariq you can
follow that tariqa a tariqa to one to a
little text here follow my snapchat
Instagram Twitter is a friend of mine
and made from acting class yeah yeah AK
when you're trying to get him on the
channel for a while
glad to be able say I don't bring enough
black people on this channel well
actually there's one girl who constantly
comment what I really ever have black
people really so [ __ ] year huh not
racist you guys check that bloggers and
check them you gotta check that box
yeah two hundred dollars in this done
yeah there's been a lot of requests
first request I saw coming for this was
from a man hey Co he wanted to react to
Conan videos in Mexico coming to Brian
one of my heroes of all time and seventh
grade when I first discovered him when I
was going to depression as a seventh
grader does over real problems man
sometimes great environment like busted
graduated high school I don't know a lot
of [ __ ] going on used to call it the
cone zone medication clone zone
medication my early rappin days rubric
you the tonin's in Mexico right now nori
turned it to Mexican Mexico avenges I
got in Mexico for this videos coding
guest stars in a Mexican telenovela
telenovela this is gonna be good it's
gonna be good let's watch this
Elliott guys wardrobe room here at
Kennedy so I'm on
we have 11 in my future would be like
lovely curse if it gets not show you
actual and I specifically asked if I
could play the role of a very sexy man
ready to be an encounter with a very
beautiful Mexican woman yes
you guys said no problem and came back
to me and I play a chief merchant what
happened well what happened what the
thing is that giving a little bit of
beatstock story she's a girl doctor as
they mistakenly think that she's people
and she grows up she becomes a beautiful
girl
and in her any chance that she will love
my character my veto gesture doesn't she
what sex world illegal which is happens
to be is what regal her lover air pushes
her boyfriend well we can going to throw
a real set
Richard
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
report our case okay so they know it
they're be admitting to the people
movement and for my uncle affair
Emily lagares Amiga mía paper over so
this teacher practice we got very angry
I believe a couple ah
[Applause]
to boost consumption you know that me
what is wanna Kazuma
so then I want a husband okay we have a
chemical manifest every time we saw
people people they appear absolute the
question personally cannot be did you
feel of the famous risk working a lot of
life I mean nobody hope that my
impression is the simulation itself
impressive no Kiro
Robocop move them to get it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Cohen I doubt that was like good
Spanish she was speaking but for the
most part home likes you seem like you
got as well yeah yeah I know a little
Spanish oh ye oh ok ok cool - Destin
child owner got this jobs I did its job
ok it's really I feel a lot of mine he
like humor especially like not like
everything that I do on YouTube but even
outside of YouTube when I interact with
people I feel like a lot of it was taken
from Conan growing up I like knowing I'm
not like the sexy masculine guy I'll
give you my hot plate like I'm dumb joke
or something got a hold it there Oh own
it nobody does this like this I was just
like y'all so shoes completely because
there's something funny and confident
about a guy who's aware he's not yes
what is risky Ingrid committing to the
bits oh wow his commitment is just yo
you can't match that ho circle that
Spanish was surprised I know yeah
because they were like ok ok then
because I seen him do other stuff that
was I can did something in Ferrari over
his on some Korean to the show anybody
couldn't get the lines down Oh like hard
for him to remember it's like barely any
lines you have it here you had a lot of
line yeah did you sound like they're
reading it really well actually what
that like / gurgling yeah yeah yeah come
on how many take it did to live like
that is you know he's been married for a
while now that's you and Cara is one of
my heroes hard but I wonder if he ever
cheat on his wife
how they interact with a lot of hot and
women that's true they're really funny
and humors the grooviest aphrodisiac
he's also like what would he like 60 70
or something Dave's giant woman like a
giant
yeah he's actually really fit - yeah man
Cullen's like you like a jack of all
trades not a lot dawns one I mean I'm
he's calling for godsakes Conan O'Brien
I have slow I mean it's slow is there in
everything else my dream as I grew up
when he was filming
but my dream has been to go on his show
and that's why I haven't ever attended a
show really of I'm like the first time I
send the Conan show I'll be a guest on
coming oh yeah like will be so about you
so cool I'll really work my way up there
to be able to go get sarangkot yeah well
with your intro be man my how danger do
you I would do his dance you do is that
I've always I've had like a dream of
doing it where like you would introduce
me and then I come out in a wig like is
it ah that is string damn [ __ ] yeah we
gotta get you on the show yeah yeah on
kkona really got to earn my way there
think things we gotta have your fans
help you always do yeah
come on would love to interview a guy
who does reactions yeah me how would
special talent right there yeah plenty
of problems a lot a lot of him hahaha
but even this girl in this show man
she's beautiful yellow she was into it
to you she wasn't that's not acting I
know a woman can act that good that's
realized I mean like look at her eyes
are eyes when he fought that was like
she's hot the beautiful thing about
acting you know work with a lot of
beautiful people yeah and you get to
have moments where you believe that are
into you that's true have it constantly
in acting class that's true you and the
one thing we did together from power 50
cent produce is he's already totally I'm
really do that now mom were talking
about you know I have drug be later
gangbangers that entire moment in that
scene I without I was totally related
aware that he's into me as like there's
no nothing in the script that I lose a
sexual tension but I knew that's what
you were doing and I fed off that really
well no why you got is acting in the
first yeah yeah yes what else into the
moment is sssss feelings
I'm emotionally unavailable in real life
so as beef man and it seemed as beer
yeah just let it all out and sing let it
all up me it means so much more to me
now I would much rather do a sex scene
in front of a film crew over real sex
any day so you're that comfortable again
I'm that comfortable why I'd be able to
do that man
I mean what uh what about sexy no I got
in front of a camera man like I mean I'm
pretty confident for the camera but sex
in front of the camera oh man right
right this is important I have a hard
time getting a hard-on for sure that's
what I'm talking about yeah like the
floor no no I not for enough they're
talking about like movie sexy oh you
thought about movie sexy holiday let's
go yeah Italy afford oh my god oh yeah
terrifying yeah everybody lodges I'm
telling you when you got to go and all
this exactly thing about poor watching
porn or like I'll be so cool to be a
porn actor because it's like [ __ ] the
top girl but that you're totally unaware
like there's like a bunch of people yeah
oh my god is not the famous Carrie
oh but I watch Conan in a porno for sure
if Conan did a porno watch when I watch
Conan Conan Conan oh boy yeah - Conan oh
loaded in Rick Dale now probably get you
on the street I'm giving against our
alright guys well thank you - hey ho hey
ho hey girl keiko hei oh wait is it -
say hei
KO we'll run with it he'll be on a anime
porno for new subscribe to the real
rejects yeah
Tariq I just keep on uTorrent this
record that is definitely very month I
every time I call it every time I say
anything I love for many months I'm like
am I saying it right a lot of people do
that a lot of people say three Tariq
yeah every once in a while I hear people
say
tarek it's mostly white people would go
mad I don't know why in LA I'm cotton my
name right way more than usual it's
weird
Wow okay well Tarek it you can find a
match to Rica it's just hard a 2-1 - I'm
snapchat Instagram Twitter keep it
lookout for a sexy black ass modeling
photos my Matt chat is Lee I do some
things on that shot thing yes he does
repeated multiple screens and then I
then I said in screenshots of me which
he never open conflict says delivers
never read that government I don't go
[Laughter]